palais du bist ob du bist fertig ja okay
ein händler
alle doch ein servus sg zuletzt
willkommen zu einem neuen video und
heute machen wir etwas was euch beim
ersten mal dass ich es gemacht habe
schon sehr sehr gut gefallen hat und
heute gibt's die zweite folge hat
richtig gewünscht und sie kommt so und
ihr werdet wahrscheinlich schon wissen
worum es geht wenn ihr den sound gehört
sound trotzdem wissen worum es geht
moment drei tage später und jetzt
vielleicht versuchen nummer 2131 so aber
ihr habt einen sound wahrscheinlich
erkannt und jetzt wisst ihr auch was
passiert wir gucken mal hier ich erstmal
hier oben in meinen augen der escort
begrüßt mich sehr schön
ok jetzt gehen wir hin ich weiß wo ich
hingehe erwarte ich von schmeißt eine
münze ist gibt es zwei ändert sich rein
gehen könnte einmal einmal 23 habe ich
in münzen kopf dann okay gut dann
schmeiß ich hier die abdeckung von
meiner livecam wenn microsoft drankommt
gehe ich in den admin channel wenn die
andere seite auf meine handfläche landet
also nach oben zeigt nicht noch mal ein
feld landet dann gehe ich in den anderen
top channel mit drei leuten ok ab mit
channel zwei leute talkshow nur drei
leute microsoft das admin anderer seite
ist okay und ihr seht hoffentlich weiß
ich es ist der top channel geboren also
gehen jetzt runter was die leute sagen
so 321 oder sind daraus gemacht egal wie
schon hin
ok dann schauen wir ein habt ihr bock
auf ein hundebett wars beldona sehr
schön da würde ich vorschlagen dass ich
meine freunde spielen
einen zweiten partner von minecraft
aufgehen ich nehme auch darauf kommt
einfach mal auf mal drauf und dann
endlich mal das scheint mir eure namen
im teamspeak betroffen unterstrich
hecken technik center stellt alles klar
kik kreft lpv phd ok jungs dann suche
ich meine webos runde raus ist jetzt
alle in der partie drin für euch
zuschauer und 4 x 32 x 4
das sieht doch ganz gut aus was soll ich
hab mit boxen an schnell ausmachen folge
nummer zwei das von euch gewünschten
format und wir spielen alles klar
damals war missachte sind die hier okay
gut geht mir gut ich glaube ich nicht
gleich nicht gibt kein entspannter
sparen sparen sparen sparen alles cool
ja wie geht's stelle ich mal kurz vor
wie alt seid ihr der reihe nach doch
gefangen von oman kurs an bord du bist
12 ja und du bist boss ok und hektik du
bist alles cool und dann haben doch
kraft du bist wie alt austritt der
cherokee jacobi ich bin ich bin ein
center stage soja dann lass uns doch mal
dieses münchen beginnen und die anderen
möglichen ecken wäre doch ganz fertig
war schon ewig gruber hier ganz
entspannt die rechte taste 20 blöcke
aber er hat wahrscheinlich auch block
ich hab auch ein schwert blöcke waren
ich wenn ich mal zu nahe wenn ich zu nah
an den rand kommen voller mich zählen
kann
genau genau da kann ich mit gesche sehr
gut alles gut kommt mit komik gerade ja
wir machen mussten sich die bußen mich
durchziehen
ok ok selbst löschen sie durch die durch
alte das vielleicht letzte runde
regierung
das müsste man schon das war sofort
gehen knapp alter das gibt es gibt sich
wir müssen aufpassen müssen aufpassen
ich hatte ich hatte eine aber irgendwann
irgendwas irgendwas war gut im griff
hatte ich plötzlich vorne grad noch mal
ein bisschen von diesem guten stein dann
ist es okay erst mal so und hier ja wo
er war egal dahin ok alles klar
jetzt kommen die jetzt kommen die
aussteht aus ich habe hef und ich will
nicht hoffen der pmg alter reihe läuft
sehr schön hektik und jetzt maschine
maschine durchmarsch auf geht's jungs
kommen egal egal egal dass du musst nur
ins bett muss nur 17 grad ab das
schaffst du das schaffst du stark stark
stark
sehr schön sehr schön
naja ok ich glaube ich habe den anderen
wiederum nicht mehr
ok jetzt ob es leben noch zwei glaube
ich okay das leben noch zwei
alles in ordnung als der 2 die runde war
krass krass kurz und es war bestimmt ein
paar minuten
einer lebt noch oder ein einziger lebt
noch ein ziel haben wir noch einen
drüben in der base ja ich bin da ich
mache ok ich weiß auch bei 39 aber der
lebt er noch ganz gut denn boden steht
ja ok alle alle reinwaschen geschaffenes
zusammen passen kanonenfutter egal
daraufhin hat die wogen aber ganz
ehrlich wenn uns jetzt noch erwischt
aber die runde ist noch nicht
entschieden
ich bin tot theoretisch kann das noch
schaffen
wir müssen nur aufpassen dass jetzt
nicht bei uns rein rutschen wir haben
dann soweit ganz gut präpariert ok ok
gold wir können einfach gold besorgen
bis wir auf dem bogen reicht das halte
ich genial wenn das blatt schon abgebaut
ist
das ist natürlich ein break zwei gold-
brauchen wir noch
oder was so probieren kommen die
probieren alle rüber jetzt alle branchen
wir haben hier gut rasiert hätte so eine
30 sekunden runde werden können oder
einfach nein als hatte mich fast alles
gut alles gut also alles ok sondern hier
noch so dass man da hoch kann jetzt ihr
noch gatte nick cannon genauso ja okay
und palais du bist du bist fertig ja ok
ein hinter alle doch eine doch oder
stones vakuums schöne runde schön kurz
und knackig aller das hat mir gefallen
ich würde sagen war ganz nett so war
relativ knapp und bevor die runde
nächste ohne ewig lang wird es schon
spät leute wir haben das jetzt mal so
hoch lass genen daumen nach oben da man
sich gefallen hat wenn ihr mehr davon
sehen wollt lasst es mich in den
kommentaren wissen wir sehen uns wieder
haut rein macht's gut und